le vote et 18 ans qu'est ce que vous en
pensez personnellement je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose
1974 c'était l'une des promesses de
campagne de valérie giscard d'estaing
alors tout juste élu président de la
république à baisser la majorité civile
électorale de 21 à 18 ans à l'époque la
france est en retard par rapport à ses
voisins européens en grande bretagne la
majorité est fixé à 18 ans depuis 1969
en allemagne depuis 1970 aida perçoit
aucune des raisons pour lesquelles les
jeunes français dès les jeunes français
ne pourrait pas exercer leur jugement ou
participer aux grandes décisions
nationales
un âge où d'autres que peuvent le faire
dans d'autres pays du monde en juin 1974
la loi est votée à l'assemblée nationale
puis au sénat cette réforme se trouve
ainsi définitivement adopté
mais il faudra attendre plusieurs mois
pour que le décret d'application entrent
en vigueur la loi est promulguée le 5
juillet 1974
conséquence de cet établissement de la
majorité plus de deux millions de jeunes
viennent grossir le corps électoral
votée à 18 ans certains y sont
favorables
moi je me trouve capable de voter et je
pense avoir de bonnes opinions
politiques
c'est bien placé et puis j'ai une bonne
idée
d'autres sont plus mesurés ça ne
m'intéresse pas tellement à 21 ans c'est
suffisant pour moi je me sens pas
tellement concernés trois ans plus tard
en 1977 des jeunes de 18 ans votent pour
la première fois aux élections
municipales en tant que jeune qui vient
en france à l'heure actuelle avec la
crise et les mauvaises conditions
d'étude par exemple je ferai un choix
totalement politique
les années passent et l'idée d'abaisser
encore l'âge de la majorité électorale
et son chemin 1994
un questionnaire est envoyé par le
gouvernement aux jeunes de 15 à 25 ans
parmi les mesures proposées
l'abaissement du droit de vote à 16 ans
uniquement pour les municipales où je
boxe 16 ans la plupart des jeunes sont
passés les gens évoluent comme les gènes
évolué non je pense rentrer c'est autre
gène finalement cette mesure n'est pas
appliquée il faut attendre 2009 pour que
le débat soit relancé à l'origine de
cette revendication
un syndicat étudiant celui de l'union
nationale lycéenne
aujourd'hui droit de vote à 16 ans il
permettrait quoi un recadrage
un rééquilibrage du corps électoral
aujourd'hui il ya plus de personnes
âgées qui va être que de jeunes là
encore c'est non la majorité électorale
reste fixé à 18 ans dans le monde
certains pays ont instauré le droit de
vote à 16 ans à l'image du brésil de
l'équateur ou encore de l'autriche
[Musique]